Really.
Really game changing reporting from The Washington
Post, the actual first United States coronavirus
death was on February 6th.
Why does this matter?
We were told we believed up until yesterday
that the first American coronavirus death
was February twenty ninth in Kirkland, Washington
State.
It's not true.
We've now learned that the first coronavirus
death in the U.S. was actually the 6th of
February.
That's more than three weeks earlier than
we thought.
Our first case that we know about was January
20th.
Now, in all likelihood, the true day of the
first case was much earlier than that.
Let's just do the math together.
We now know the first death was February 6th
in Santa Clara, California.
OK.
We also had a February 17th death in Santa
Clara, California, both earlier than the official
previously known case.
Both of these people died at home.
They were posthumously tested for Corona virus
and they tested positive.
So here's why it matters.
The entire timeline is different of the outbreak
and of our understanding.
If the first death was actually February 6th,
number one, we don't know how these two people
became infected.
They got it from someone.
If one person died on February 6th and typically
it's taking 17 days for people to die for
lack of a better term, they probably had their
first symptoms on January 20th with a two
to 14 day incubation.
That means that this person likely contracted
the virus anywhere between January 6, then
12th source or something like that.
That means that we had infections in the country
in early January.
Public health officials so far are saying
they believe this person was infected in their
community because their travel history doesn't
suggest that they were somebody who brought
it back early from China or another country.
So that means someone else had it in California
in early January or even in late December.
Secondly, this is important because it implies
that a lot of early 2010 2020, rather, what's
called ally influenza like illness and influenza
like illness, death was misdiagnosed as flu
or as primary pneumonia not caused by Cauvin
19 or other respiratory disease.
So the second reason this is important is
a bunch of deaths believed to be flu or other
things in January and February.
Some of those were likely coronavirus deaths
as well.
So the death toll is likely higher than the
official one.
And number three, this is really important
because we talk about models, we talk about
contagion models, case models, death rate
models.
Something that's really important for epidemiologists
is when did this start?
That hugely affects models and the curves
that we anticipate.
If this actually started weeks earlier than
we thought, it implies way more people have
it today than we think.
And it has wide ranging implications.
And I've mentioned this before.
My girlfriend had a respiratory thing in mid-January.
It never got super serious.
Flu was ruled out.
It lasted more than two weeks.
In retrospect, it could have been mild coronavirus.
We had just come back from Europe towards
the end of her having it.
I got it when I mentioned this to people a
month ago.
A lot of people dismissed it, said, David,
you're being alarmist.
There was no cobh it in the U.S. in mid-January,
in late January and early February when you
had it.
And everybody who gets it gets a fever.
Well, we now know there was covered in January
wheat because someone died on February 6th.
We know a ton of people never get a fever.
Did she have covered 19?
I have no idea.
But it doesn't seem outrageous that a lot
more people than we believe have had this.
Now, that does imply a far lower fatality
rate.
That's a good thing.
But it implies it's much more contagious than
maybe we believe.
We won't know until we have a reliable antibody
test.
RELIABLE, but being an important word there.
So a very important report in that we hear
January 20, we had one case and February 29,
we had the first death.
Someone died on the 6th.
They had it in January.
They hadn't traveled, meaning they got it
from someone else.
There was almost certainly coronavirus in
the U.S. in early January, maybe even in late
December or earlier.
Will we ever know that that that specifically?
I don't know how much more we will know, but
this certainly points in that direction.
Let me know what you think.
I am on Twitter at David Pakman, and I would
love to hear from you.
Let's take a quick break.
So much to talk about today.
And Stephanie Kelson will be joining us once
again.